auch hey leute hier sind wahrscheinlich
am dümmsten kit des heutigen tages hier
mit dr sprits mir was hundekacke und
heck rekord
davos sg zh und herzlich willkommen zu
einem video das ist so noch nicht gab
zumindest nicht auf meinem channel denn
wenn die ganzen leute immer weg gehen
bzw wenn peer gynt erkennen wir dass dem
team oder server sind und ich habe das
richtig lustiges entdeckt und zwar gibt
es hier auf dem team oder server die
warteschlange funktionen und da ohne
witz man spielt mit gegen leute mit dem
behinderten kids die es überhaupt gibt
wo man sich alles selbst kräften muss
keine ahnung was und ich finde es mega
unterhaltsames wegen werde ich das jetzt
machen werden paar runden spielen ich
werde euch zusammen schneiden ich hoffe
es gefällt euch wenn ihr mehr lachen
wollt wenn ich daraus zu machen soll
anlass waren daumen nach oben wenn euch
das video gefallen hat ende natürlich
erstmal anschauen und schreibt in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet und ich
würde sagen wir legen einfach mal aus so
und der erste ist noch relativ basic
hier wird er wird wirken keinesfalls
sein okay der double dip ist deaktiviert
doch alle im block hätten deshalb möchte
meine maus kann überhaupt nicht fassen
who bisher c-max robben mit suppen
heilung machen keine ahnung gar nicht
kann der alex alle er hat also ein gift
rang gelandet als allererste versuchen
den tiefs platzieren
glaub ich alex pure was ist los bei dir
aleks und sowie beide erhielt danke alex
grube ist ein sehr sehr netter buch es
muss ja auch mal eintritt und ich zum 6
aber jetzt muss drauf gehen hat er nicht
geteilt die wahrheit lieber weggehen
sollen von mir als in dem moment hat
aber nicht gemacht und deswegen gehen
wir für die nächste runde doch für uns
eigentlich bisher
warteschlange hallo du bist du okay hier
infinity ward und ecke vor dem
serbien-spiel ich wolf killer lth wie
vergrössern an dich wolftäler was hast
du nur kollege ist ein geiles kanada
okay okay ich kenne ja kürzlich hätten
seltsam aber ich kann ihn nicht retten
muss ich sagen ihr habt vielleicht
abgesehen war irgendwie komisch aber
noch für uns entschieden gottseidank
brauche ich finde das so mega geil ist
ist so geil
hammer hat die mir dass das gefällt mir
richtig gut so ist es erstmal immer
analysieren was man hat ungenügend der
gäste gar keine zeit
der bogen hat auch noch enfinity drauf
kein power bogen alles gesehen heute
bögen mit power 5 oder so also ganz ganz
verrückte sachen okay ist auch oberst im
sommer der sich die slicks ist erlaubt
kann bringt ihm aber nichts denn ich
mehr betreffe unternehmen
die g8 die ganze vergessen jiechi
zusammen schreiben wurde
es tut mir leid ich hätte mir kommt der
einen verfügten wie wärs wenn ich
einfach indem in diesem modus hier oder
in der serie einfach immer so ein
bisschen gegen die leute spiele mit
deren kids okay weil es mit dem los hab
ich ihn erwischt habe ich hab mich nicht
erwischt und dann am ende vielleicht
noch mal am ende so als als element des
formats am ende noch mal eine runde
gegen richtig gegen typ mit einem
richtig behinderten kind machen wenn ich
mehr bock drauf es zeichnet ist schon
eine geile sache hier sport hyper okay
das ist auf jeden fall so richtig
behindertes geht und was wir hier lockt
er ist auf jeden fall
bis 5 the [ __ ] und flambeau what the
[ __ ] alter ja dann lass uns mal lustig
das ist hammerhart
ich muss auf jeden fall eine kleine
schwert combo reinbekommen den guten
dann sieht er trifft es eigentlich gut
ausgeht für uns okay okay
wie war sie schnell dauern krass aber
das ist schon geil ist etwa schon geldes
geht hammer geil sagt auer 4 und 13
ach du scheiße das ist ein richtiges
derby steht immer die rüstung hat auch
protection drei auch drauf also geht
schon aber ist ein kind dann wird man
hier mit voller rüstung spiel wenn man
wahrscheinlich tut oder so können wir
mal mit geben leute gekündigt wogegen
trifft kann gucke ich das an es ist eine
schande für die ganze nachbarschaft
knapp base freut mich übrigens was ich
noch sagen heute was leute das ist
wieder so ein fall war es laut kit alter
ja okay du brennst da kannst du die
löschen man überall bringe gar nichts
von ihr der mit sportchef mich wird das
weg was für ein kind mit einem puffer
fisch alter der fortune drauf hat der
glücksfee
ich fass es nicht okay eine runde kann
man glaube ich noch machen leute
eine rolle könne man noch machen bzw
machen die noch und dann suchen
vielleicht noch einmal richtig
behinderten kind heraus die summe heraus
sehr korrekt des deutsch immer gut
getäuschte es geht also kein noch so
schöne combo amsterdam stay jenny from
the block von ihm aber auch new halbes
herzo mein gott wo also leute ich wollte
noch bis er ihm sagen jetzt bis gerade
eben habe ich euch jeden kampf gezeigt
den ich gemacht habe
also lief ganz gut wir fragen jetzt
einfach mal wer hat das
behindert warum glas what the [ __ ] mein
gott wie sind es ist das warum hat ihr
glas hier
wer kommt auf die idee sich glas in pvp
kit reinzumachen what the [ __ ] ja okay
ist vielleicht posten auf splash prüfen
ist und dass man loslegen leger oder
dafür feierten kommt sie dann schwert
diesmal dein schwert nancy er muss jetzt
auch so machen lassen
aber mit ein bisschen abstand nicht dass
mich direkt weg lacht ja okay das ist
richtig hohes level
das ist ein richtig hohe speed level
leute hier sind ja wahrscheinlich am
dümmsten kit des heutigen tages hier mit
dr sprits mir was hundekacke und heck
recorder sv nieder
der harry potters freund utah wtf
vassili alter ist dass hacker und geiler
der alex bubel es ist ja alex puppe
wieder der mit den boss kids alex du
bist guter bubel alex du bist ein guter
bube ich wollte nur sagen dass du da
bist wie viel mir bedeutet man lieber
alex pöllhuber treiber nicht so viel
entities beschwören mitmachen will
alex du bist du alex bube ob das hühner
wien aspern leben ein
ich nicht naja leute das war's für die
heute hier folge keine ahnung wie es
nennen soll turnier action keine ahnung
schreibt mal in die kommentare was ein
guter name für das format wer würde mich
sehr interessieren
alle die jetzt so dranbleiben haben
jetzt die einmalige chance dem
formatieren namen zu geben falls sie
denn wollte das informatik ich finds
mega light übrigens
übrigens ich wollte nur sagen also
lassen daumen nach oben da man sich
gefallen hat und wie gesagt in die
kommentare
wollt ihr mehr davon wie das heißt es
beim nächsten video wieder autoren
macht's gut und scharf